>> Bill: IT’S 9:30 HERE IN
NEW YORK.
A TOP UROLOGIST IN CHINA
DEFENDING HER RESEARCH.
THE FORMER AT CDC DIRECTOR
SITTING DOWN FOR AN INTERVIEW WI
FOX.
IT DR. SIEGEL SPENT TWO HOURS
WITH HIM OVER THE WEEKEND.
DOCTOR, GOOD MORNING TOO.
WHAT DID YOU WILL EARN
COURSEWORK >> A YEAR AND A HALF
AGO, DR. WRIGHT FIELD HAD A
HYPOTHESIS.
>> IN THE LABORATORY IT WAS
EDUCATED, EVOLVED, SO IT BECAME
A VIRUS THAT COULD EFFICIENTLY
TRANSFER BETWEEN HUMAN HUMAN.
THAT IS THE IS THE HOPE BY THE
SUPPORT.
ANTHONY FOUND TO.
>> HE LONG BELIEVES THAT IT
BECAME FROM AN ANIMAL
INTERMEDIARY.
HE HAS ONLY RECENTLY CONCEDED
THAT THERE MIGHT BE A DIFFERENT
THEORY.
>> WHEN SCIENTISTS BITE INTO A
BONE ON HYPOTHESIS, IT’S HARD
FOR THEM TO MOVE ON.
IF I’M DISAPPOINTED ABOUT
ANYTHING ABOUT THE EARLY
SCIENTIFIC COMMUNITY, THERE
SEEMS TO BE A LACK OF OPENNESS
TO PURSUE BOTH HYPOTHESES.
>> ROBERT REDFIELD HAD A HIGHER
SECURITY CLEARANCE THAN OTHERS
ON THE TASK FORCE GIVING HIM A
EARLY KNOWLEDGE ON THE VIRUS HAS
CHARACTERISTICS THAT OTHERS ON
THE JUST DIDN’T HAVE.
MUCH THAT HE HAD WAS CLASSIFIED
AND DATA LIKE THIS NEEDS TO BE
SHARED WHITER TO PROTECT
AMERICANS.
>> THE FIRST CRITICAL ERROR WAS
WE CALLED THE SARS LIKE.
IT IS NOT SARS LIKE.
AND BY CALLING IT SARS LIKE, WE
MOUNTED A HEALTH RESPONSE THAT
WAS MIRRORED OFF OF SARS.
COVID IS NOTHING LIKE SARS.
IT IS LARGELY ASYMPTOMATIC.
AT THAT STRATEGY THAT WE STARTED
IN JANUARY AND FEBRUARY AND
FINALLY FIGURED OUT AS WE GOT
INTO MARCH THAT WAS IN THE
SITUATION HERE.
IT WAS FLAWED.
>> DR. REDFIELD CLAIMS IT WAS A
BIG MISTAKE THAT HIS TEAM IS NOT
ALLOWED INTO THE WUHAN LAB WHEN
THE VIRUS WAS FIRST IDENTIFIED
IN JANUARY OF 2020.
HE SAID HE SHOULD’VE PUSHED
HARDER TO GET IN RIGHT AWAY AND
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
WAS TO COMPROMISE TO HELP.
>> I THINK THEY WERE HIGH REALLY
COMPROMISED.
THEY WERE INCAPABLE OF
COMPELLING CHINA TO ADHERE TO
GLOBAL HEALTH BECAUSE THEY
DIDN’T DO THAT.
THEY ALLOWED CHINA TO PICK THAT
SCIENTISTS ALLOWED HIM TO
INVESTIGATE.
>> MANIPULATING VIRUSES MAY NOT
BE A BRIEF SEARCH WE ARE
PREPARED TO BE DOING.
HE WARNED AGAINST WHAT HE CALLED
GOING ON A PATH OF SCIENTIFIC
ARROGANCE.
>> Bill: DOCTOR, IF YOU COULD
PUT A FINE POINT ON THIS.
I WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR ABOUT
THIS.
THERE ARE EYES ON THIS THING IN
DECEMBER, FOR SURE IN JANUARY
AND FEBRUARY.
WHEN DID HE START THINKING ABOUT
THE VIROLOGY LAB IN WUHAN?
>> HE STARTED THINKING ABOUT IT
IN THE VERY BEGINNING.
AND DECEMBER AND JANUARY.
THEN HE STARTED ACCUMULATING
EVIDENCE THROUGH THE
STATE DEPARTMENT AND NATIONAL
SECURITY COUNCIL THAT VERIFIED
THE SUSPICION THAT HE HAD.
HE TOLD ME THAT THE TASK FORCE
WAS NOT FOCUSED ON THAT.
THEY WERE FOCUSED ON WHAT WAS
GOING ON HERE AND THE
UNITED STATES SO HIS VOICE WAS
DROWNED OUT.
>> Dana: I THINK WHAT I’VE
LEARNED FROM THERE TO REALLY
FOCUS IN ON WAS WHEN
DR. REDFIELD SAID THAT BECAUSE
WE DID NOT KNOW ABOUT THE
ORIGINS, WE WERE TREATING THIS
LIGHT AS A SARS LIKE VIRUS WHICH
WAS THE WRONG THING TO DO.
WE ARE ABOUT TO COME UP ON THE
600,000 AMERICAN TO DIE.
THAT’S WHY YOU NEED TO KNOW HOW
THESE THINGS GET STARTED.
THAT’S WHY CHINA SHOULD’VE
COOPERATED IN THE FIRST PLACE.
>> THAT’S TRUE TRUE.
ACCORDING TO DR. REDFIELD, THAT
MASSIVE ASYMPTOMATIC SPREAD THAT
BECAUSE THE VIRUS TO RIFLE
THROUGH OUR COMMUNITIES AND HOW
CONTAGIOUS IT WAS WAS
SPECIFICALLY DUE TO THAT.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT THE
ORIGINS PLAY AN EXACT ROLE IN.
>> Bill: THIS IS ANOTHER FINE
POINT HERE AS WE LOOK BACK ON
THIS.
ASYMPTOMATIC SPREAD TO.
I DON’T BELIEVE THAT WE REALLY
UNDERSTOOD THAT UNTIL MID-MARCH.
HERE IN NEW YORK WE WERE LIVING
OUR LIVES.
MADISON SQUARE GARDEN HAD TEN
DIFFERENT EVENTS OVER A SPAN OF
SEVEN OR NINE DAYS.
THE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE THAT WOULD CYCLE THROUGH
MADISON SQUARE GARDEN FOR A
HOCKEY GAME OR AN NBA GAME OR A
COLLEGE BASKETBALL GAME.
THE POSSIBILITY REMAINS THAT A
LOT OF THESE PEOPLE COULD HAVE
BEEN EXPOSED TO IT.
THEY GO OUT IN THE COMMUNITY
OVER THE NEXT TEN, 14 DAYS, THEY
ARE SPREADING IT.
IS THAT HOW WE NOW UNDERSTAND
THE MISTAKE OR FAULT IN NOT
UNDERSTANDING COVID IN THE
BEGINNING?
>> EXACTLY.
REDFIELD KNEW BEFORE EVERYONE
ELSE.
HE HE SAID HE WISHES THAT HE
WOULD’VE DONE MANHATTAN PRODUCT
OF TESTING.
>> Bill: BASED ON THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION’S REPORT IN
MARCH, DOES HE THINK THAT THE
LEAK WAS ACCIDENTAL OR DONE WITH
INTENT?
>> FROM EVERYTHING THAT I
GLEANED FROM THAT TWO HOURS, HE
DOES NOT BELIEVE THAT THE LEAK
WAS ON PURPOSE.
HE BELIEVES IT WAS ACCIDENTAL.
BUT WAS PERHAPS NOT I ACCIDENTAL
WAS WHAT WAS GOING ON IN THE LAB